alors c'est vrai que les collègues ont
déjà évoqué des sujets qui me tiennent
aussi à cœur par rapport à mon
territoire mais j'irai droit au but en
Guyane française il y a trois ans les
opérateurs c'était associés pour réduire
la zone blanche entre cours et ici à
Marie soit une soixantaine de kilomètres
mais il reste encore la zone blanche
entre cinnamaris et Saint-Laurent soit
près de 200 km quotidiennement des
centaines de guyanais empruntent cette
route et ne peuvent appeler les secours
en cas d'accident il en est de même pour
la route entre Kayes Regina soit 183 km
moi je pense que vous connaissez mon
territoire la Guyane une seule
infrastructure routière tout le long du
littoral sachez que il y a des communes
de l'Intérieur qui sont enclavés qui
n'ont pas de route qui n'ont pas de
couverture numérique c'est vrai qu'on
parlait tout à l'heure du timbre rouge
on parlait du du du on parle de maison
de service public mais c'est clair que
son numérique c'est pas possible voilà
alors madame la Présidente je voudrais
vous poser une question que comptez-vous
faire pour obliger les opérateurs de
respecter leurs engagements merci
beaucoup je vais parler de la Guyane il
y a un appel en cours à candidature sur
l'attribution de fréquence en Guyane
actuellement dans le cadre de cet appel
à candidature l'ARCEP préalablement à
cet appel à candidature à travailler
avec les collectivités avec la
collectivité de Guyane pour identifier
les zones qui doivent être couverts et
les obligations qui doivent être mis
pour les opérateurs dans le cadre de cet
appel à candidature donc on a veillé à
faire ça et à ce travail avec les
collectivités pour améliorer la
couverture en Guyane